with smoking killing 700 000 europeans
each year meps have endorsed a new
regime on how cigarettes are branded and
marketed the main aim to discourage
youngsters from starting smoking the
main means bigger and bolder on the
packet health warnings flavorings banned
and additives listed and more regulation
for e-cigarettes all of this despite
intense lobbying from the industry the
lobby about russia and disaster we
i have a european dream said the czech
president to meps during this week's
plenary yes to europe yes to common
rules integration and harmonization euro
has been a stabilizing factor for
economic development
what we need is common fiscal policy
harmonization of taxation
resounding support for a new automated
road accident alert program spanning the
eu known as equal the idea is that your
vehicle will alert europe's 112
emergency services number via satellite
transmitting details of the severity and
location of the crash so rescuers can be
scrambled more quickly and know better
how to react it could save 2 500 lives
every year out of the let's say 28
thousands that are killed every minute
counts in a golden hour the program
could also prevent hit and run accidents
car makers have until 2015 to equip new
vehicles for e-call but that could be
extended the idea goes to member states
next for their view